what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
it's a new day which means
a new spider-man league because it seems
like we are getting them pretty much
every day at this point sadly the only
thing that we really aren't getting
is that trailer but today we actually do
have some really cool leaks to hold us
over
yesterday we kind of got a look at a new
spider-man suit that tom holland is
going to be rocking in no way home
and today we get an even better look at
it thanks to some new toy leaks that we
got from funko pop
and other people as well now we get a
better look at the suits but we also
kind of get a description about one suit
which is pretty revealing and it looks
like
peter parker our peter parker is going
to be using some magic
in no way home now obviously doctor
strange is going to be
a pretty big part of this movie and it
is going to be a multiversal
magical film so it would make sense that
peter parker would get a kind of
magical suit to help him deal with
everything that is about to go down
in spiderman no way home but don't worry
i'll break it all down for you
two new suits today and talk about what
they actually mean
and if you love spider-man and want to
stay up to date on everything that is
happening with no way home be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos so we always find it
interesting
that when one toiley kind of gets out
the other toy leaks kind of start to
pile out as well slash some of the
companies actually just straight up
release them and today that's kind of
what we have a combination of in fact
some of these have even been posted to
marvel's official website
so whether these were leaked or not they
are all 100
legitimate interesting strategy but
again this is hollywood's worst
kept secret by far so the two suits that
we're going to be talking about today
is this new black and gold spider-man
suit that peter parker is going to get
and the suit that we kind of saw
yesterday
the red blue and gold one that is
seemingly going to be fused or
integrated with magic and i'll explain
that in just a bit but the black suit
has
actually three toy reveals for it so we
know that this
is indeed going to be a suit that he is
going to be wearing throughout the film
otherwise
why would these toy companies make three
different toys that look
exactly the same what we have today is
one giant sized funko pop for the black
and gold suit and then we have a hasbro
titan hero series one with the black and
gold suit and then just a normal action
figure
again with the black and gold suit and
it looks pretty good this is definitely
an
upgrade from the night monkey suit and
it may be used kind of for that same
reason maybe so he could be kind of
incognito at night time we do know that
peter parker is going to be taking
refuge in the sanctum but we do know
that he is still a wanted man and if he
goes
outside of the sanctum he's going to
have to kind of hide his identity so
people don't recognize him and
technically spider-man
is kind of a bad guy in the mcu at this
point at least that's what people think
so he can't really be rocking the same
spider-man suit because people are going
to know it's him and he's going to get
chased by the authorities but overall i
think this suit actually looks pretty
dang good and as far as what it's called
if we take a look at the funko pop that
is only being sold at target
it says spider-man black and gold suit
that's all it says now there was a list
of funkos that was leaked
yesterday and there wasn't a description
that said black and gold suit there is
one that says
spider-man no way home gold suit and
there is one that says spider-man no way
home
upgraded suit so perhaps this is the
upgraded suit yes this does have a lot
of gold on it but i wouldn't call it a
gold
suit the gold suit we actually probably
haven't seen yet
and the reason is because the other
suits are called the integrated suit
which we know and i'm about to talk
about
and this black and gold suit which again
i wouldn't call a gold suit because it's
more black than anything
so it looks like there could be a secret
gold suit out there that we don't really
know about yet because we haven't seen
it perhaps they are going to manage to
keep at least
one secret from us before we finally see
the movie now i think the coolest leak
that we've gotten by far
in a pretty long time with spider-man no
way home
is this new suit called the integrated
suit this is the suit that we kind of
saw yesterday with the toy leagues this
is a red blue and gold suit and really
what this looks like
is a kind of upgraded iron spider suit
with
one very very different change and that
is the fact that it looks like
spider-man can use magic with this suit
now if we think about it one not only is
this ridiculously cool this is going to
be
a completely new way to see spider-man
with him not only web slinging but
using magic which is just going to be an
incredible sight but
two this makes a ton of sense if you
consider
everything that we know about the movie
so far it makes sense we know that this
is going to be
a multiversal spider-verse film
and we know that there's not just going
to be one villain there are going to be
multiple villains and some of these
villains or actually a lot of them
are going to be coming from other
universes it's not going to be enough
for peter to simply
fight them and defeat them they're going
to have to send them back to whatever
universe they came from and that could
be where the magic comes in
now in this photo of the funko pop we
see a magical rune in his hand but we
also see something on his chest
now it's called integrated suit because
it is integrated with
magic from doctor strange and possibly
wong and i for one would really love to
see doctor strange's cloak of levitation
on spider-man as well
but we'll have to wait and see if that
happens on that one but it's clear that
doctor strange enhances spider-man's
suit with his magic
now whether or not this is simply a
spell cast upon peter by doctor strange
or maybe perhaps he is wearing some type
of a necklace that gives him powers
that's unknown at this point but what
does seem very clear is that peter
parker is going to be using magic in
spider-man no way home and this is
really going to give us a spectacle that
we've never seen before in terms of
spider-man on screen him
using magic so essentially we now have a
character that is strange
and spider-man combined and i am really
really excited to be able to see this on
screen
now as far as the other funko pops are
concerned that were released today we do
have
the far from home suit that was made at
the end by peter parker with the webb
wings it looks like he's going to be
wearing that probably in the beginning
of the movie we have a funko pop of ned
we have a funko pop of mj and then we
have a rather
curious funko pop of doctor strange it
looks like he's kind of wearing normal
clothes and he has a shovel in his hand
also he has the eye of agamotto on his
neck still which is interesting because
he does not have the time stone anymore
and if you look at his rune on his right
hand
it's yellow and not green like it
normally is so i have a lot of questions
including why he has a shovel in his
hand it's clearly important enough to
where they made a funko pop of it
perhaps there were some ancient
magical books that they hid underground
or something like that and he asked to
go dig them up
not sure but again it's clearly
important if they made an actual funko
pop with him holding the shovel
now as far as when the spiderman no way
home trailer is going to come i
definitely think
now it's going to be after loki i have
had some people that work at movie
theaters tell me that the trailer is
going to be coming with black widow on
july 9th
however we have heard this before and
things can always change
especially when really big leaks like
this get out and everybody's talking
about them
including myself perhaps more than
anybody as well but anyways
today nick santos from that show.com
tweeted this also some bad news but i'm
hearing now
that the no way home trailer is now
expected to drop
closer to september most likely closer
to chiang chi
now obviously this is not good news and
i also do remember
daniel rpk stating that we were going to
get another
shanxi and another eternals trailer
before we got the spiderman no way home
trailer and that lines up with what nick
from that hashtag show is stating
because if it is closer to shanghi then
we'll definitely get another trailer for
shanxi and we'll probably get an
eternals one as well
now that doesn't mean we won't get it
this month because the rumor has been
for a while that it was going to be june
or july
and we still could very much get this at
the end of this month which obviously is
july because still
the end of july is closer to september
he didn't say it was going to drop in
september he said closer to september so
we can assume that that's the end of
this month
it looks like sony and marvel are still
preparing a little bit for the trailer
and their marketing for whatever they're
going to do
and i actually kind of think that these
toy leaks are a part of their marketing
program
everybody in the world pretty much is
asking for the no way home trailer
and all of a sudden these toy leaks come
out not gonna lie i kind of feel like
they did it on purpose to kind of give
us something to get us off their backs
but who knows and hopefully the trailer
comes out pretty soon and of course as
always if i hear
anything i'll be sure to let everybody
know so be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos be sure
to like the video and let me know what
you think about it in the comments down
below for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof